walk him to this video on playing
scissors from finland i recently lost
the game against him in the Trump so I
played one he six just avoid the Trump
not that I'm completely afraid of
intimate of it but I really forgot to
look up this side line that he had
played and I had to add huge problems
really with with this so I'm just
developing normally and we'll probably
get some sort of tirage defense Ellis's
this is a tirage 93d five okay
interesting yeah can i maybe switch back
to end to a head shop maybe I'm a bit
yeah this is the bigger the light on c6
is not well placed for the Hedgehog but
still maybe I can Mia what about ff5
versus or phir bhi 598 then d 697
interesting because this c6 is rather
weak I'm not sure about that
maybe I can play some more and
strengthening moves you have a five
let's see maybe he commits to something
ah maybe I can play just might be eight
you know are taking the pawn on c4
that's interesting because now a five is
gaining a bit in strength takes Knight
exes completely unplayable oh I can now
he can we can only play a night a 2 or
something to cover the point so he
really has to advance it and now i'm
going to play light to see 5 with the
tempo later these six and 97
ok sure ok let's start with that and
then 97
yeah that's Nocturne not cleared or this
position quite quite interesting
strategically speaking also after 95 the
light squared Bishop sigh exchange their
SSC 6 square that can be M can be a
morir problem
yeah he's putting some pressure on busy
guy but Bishop f6 I can play Bishop
takes f6 shouldn't be a big issue yeah I
hope night c5 light takes D takes Bishop
b5 Bishop d6 I hope that this is
playable that's very tricky should be
6656 Queen a 498 and it should be ok but
it's very shaky openness I didn't
consider at all why would he
strengthened lime a structured give me
the bishops ok well i mean the bishop
pair is not worth much because of this
move but still quite surprising ok just
take it and we'll just just take it and
maybe here lots not sure
I should be okay for like I mean
shouldn't be in trouble this night is
not having check any particularly great
ideas at the moment ok the night is the
the somewhat better pc a long term
especially in a night against bishop
ending but but still I don't really
think like sugar should lose this ratio
is those pawns on the dark squares here
with the dark squared Bishop still being
on the board now but I don't really
think it's a big problem
yeah 1d three years might be a good
place for the for the night
ok
okay don't like it so much to trade that
the trade but it still shouldn't be an
issue he had this night c5 idea this is
why I am going back going back to c7
yeah I don't think knight c6 is any good
yeah should just this is ok for what he
did I can probably panel efore g4 should
I play a 5v5 form I can do that online
morning now ki forgot again he has G for
him he's got G form and I forgot about
that that was silly I Karacan can maybe
I can do that okay I can't I can still
playing that check check check okay
maybe I'm still okay but it wasn't
necessary at all how I played this not
at all check
now that that's getting tricky yeah how
idiotic can you be on just just just an
idiot yeah I should never ever lose this
I e5 was just totally mistimed
check I can just take this yeah if Isis
was totally totally erotic I forgot that
he has this G forms I was thinking just
before take stakes here and f5 and no
problem but he has g4 of course and this
is what I forgot I forgot about this
move if I don't play you five there's
simply nothing happening I could play
Bishop d6 and just stay that's
absolutely nothing going on i D otic
simply idiotic yeah after that I don't
think I can still hold it now this was
probably the relay be the relatively
best trine I g2 also was good him check
check check no that's just the loss i
mean at the enter if he gets to this
situation here with the night against
the bishop it so it's losing the problem
is this invasion route which I which I
opened up for him with this a 5 firm
idiocy they were just stay here I just
need to stay here and there's absolutely
nothing going on it just totally dead
this position yeah just a bad play if I
were just are just very bad um yeah
that's bad okay thanks for watching